hello everyone welcome to another most
excellent game from the 2019 FIBA World
Cup again a lot we have requested this
one is a ferocious versus Daniel Dube of
current world rapid champion and also a
second to Magnus crossing during the
World Chess Championship match last year
in London so if there's a obviously if
there's one thing you don't want to do
you don't want to take this match into
the rapid section you wanna well if
possible you want to close it during the
classic section so let's check it out a
clash between the two young twenty seven
hundredths or or maybe do both still
isn't 2700 maybe he believe he's a few
points off 2,700 life twenty six ninety
something but still to to extremely
strong players so let's see how the game
went with E for by ali reza c5 at the
Sicilian defense is on the border which
is not a surprise since he was a part of
Magnus Coulson's team during the
preparation for the World Chess
Championship night of three Knight to c6
and now Bishop to b5 Jerusalem oh not
going for d4 with g6 castles by future
in the bush of the g7 we have c3 Knight
to f6 preparing the castle we have
looked at a one defending the pawn and
do both castles with h3 and the Queen to
b6 asking white what do you want to do
with this bishop first all the reza
pushes a for defends it and now a6
asking do you want to maybe bring it
back bishop to f1 do you wanna go back
up c4 maybe cap from c6 and here ali
reza trades with a bunch of characters
and here there is one game from 1992
where Queen captures and c6 was played
in a game
Vladimir Kostich versus a Stefan bug
burger a game in the draw but hereafter
be captures on c6 it's already as of
move 9 that we had a completely new game
so let's see how it went if we five by
ferocious attacking the knight Knight to
d5 and now a5 pushing the Queen further
back preparing Queen to a4 after after
d6 displayed as Black has to play d6 at
some point you wanna at least somehow
try to develop this light Square
if you allow black to push for example
a5 then black can develop the light
square bishop using this diagonal which
is not something you want to do so Queen
back to d8 and now d3 with d6 by black
and now Queen to a4 as planned a going
after well the c6 pawn with D captures
on e5 and now you could go for Queen
captures on c6 then black would go after
your d3 point so dubov decides to trade
on e5 with knight characters and here
Bishop captures on e5 with rook captures
on e5 and now Queen to d6 defending the
pawn attacking the rook rook back there
he won and now Bishop to f5
finally the bishop it has been developed
the rooks are now connected in black and
start organizing his forces and here
Knights the a3 asking black do you want
a capture on d3 and you could capture on
d3 but it turns into a really
complicated game for example if you play
Bishop captures on d3 then Bishop to h6
comes with an attack on the rook and the
ones the rook moves then you get rook a
to d1 and now you have the rook on this
Dagon this file where there are a lot of
black pieces and you cannot cement with
c4 you have to play it but then you just
get a trader and you give up your light
square bishop for example Knight
captures Bishop captures and after Queen
captures on c4 you get a disposition
it's a playable but there are better
moves for black men capturing yes such
as the one dubov chose rook F the e8 now
Bishop to h6 will not come with an
attack on the rook and Knight to c4
attacking the Queen forcing the Queen to
move back we have Queen to c7 still
keeping an eye on the c6 pawn and now
Bishop to e3 offering the d3 pawn for
the c5 pawn but a dubov decides to trade
with Knight captures on d3 rook captures
on e3 now defending the d3 pawn and now
rook a to d8 with a double attack
against the pawn here and now Knight to
e5 defending the pawn here and now with
a double attack against the c6 pawn and
it's not easy to defend this pawn for
example if you try rook to c8 to defend
it then you get Queen c4 with the
Queen captures on f7 threat and after
you defend this app because you have to
then you lose the a6 pawn on the other
hand if you try something like Bishop to
d7 to defend it then you get the Queen
to f4 again with the same idea you're
gonna attack the f7 pawn and once this
is defended let's say go back then
Knight captures on g6 just wins the pawn
as your queen is attacked on c7 you have
to trade here and out the knight nicely
guards the pawn back if you try a 5 if
you want to take this variation further
to kick away the defender of the d3 pawn
you get rook a e1 you don't really care
about black capturing here because your
rook is hanging so after f6 Knight h5
now threatening Knight captures on f6
with a nice fork and all you know well
after that is the defendant you're gonna
go rook to f3 and again black cannot
capture here if you capture you lose and
f6 with check if you capture with the
Ruby then you lose the bishop so all in
all it's not possible to defend the c6
pawn duo found f6 he decided to trade
Queens well giving up a pawn but it's a
double C pawn so hopefully it will be it
will be alright and I forgot to mention
in the first game of the match was drawn
where dubov had the white pieces Queen
captures on c6 now Queen this 6 of
course Google wants the trade here at to
fix his pawn structure with Queen
captures he capture some B 6 and knight
back to g4 rook captures on e 3f
captures an eatery and now Du Bois can
grab the pawn on d3 but first he was
rook to b8 now threatening the be to
pawn as well he wants to activate his
rook with Knight captures on f6 with
check King g7 and now Knight to d5 with
rook captures on b2 as planned and now e
for butter back to D 7 and now comes
roof to F 1 preparing rook to f6 to
start the gobbling up pawns from behind
with Bishop to e6 now attacking the
knight and also now rook to f6
will not come with the threat of
captures but now Knight the c7 attacking
the bishop and the a6 pawn bishop back
to D 7 and here white white could have
gone for c4
and well in expectation of Luke 282
going after the e5 pawn now you go back
95 prepare rook to f6 and after rook
captures an a5 you're going to go look
to f6 Bishop to c6 you're going to
capture here for example captures
captures and now White has two very
dangerous connected passed pawns in the
center whereas black has a past a pawn
but this would obviously be extremely
good for white Abbott a ferocious found
a different line he played Knight
captures on a6 first but this allows
black
well a sort of a defense bishop sorry
rook to b7 not allowing night to retreat
we are the c7 square also you cannot
retreat here as the pawn is covering the
be for square and now blacks plan is to
just keep harassing the night rook to a7
I looked to be some Lucas and rook to b7
and claim a draw and take the game into
the rapid section as dubov is the world
rapid champion so C 4 and now Bishop th
first a very important move otherwise if
you play rook to e7 right away Knights
the b8 would come with an attack and the
bishop so you have to clear the bishop
first and now after the bishop move like
I said now if you play something like
King H to Luke a7 is just a forced draw
you will get a repetition of most night
here Ruby 7 I back rookie 7 I back up
here and the and so on now so here we
would have a draw by threefold
repetition but here Raja found a very
interesting line which kinda doesn't
allow this repetition he played b5 and
ok Google said ok that's that's a move
the the point is if you capture on e5
the knight can then capture on c5 so you
don't want to allow this so dubov
continued with his plan rook to e7 he
wants to draw and take the game into the
rapid night the b8 and the rope the b7
ferrara repeated we have group night to
a6 rook to a7 and the Knights to b8 here
rope to b7 by duo and here if Raja
repeats then again we have a draw by
threefold repetition but Roger had
something else in mind so feel free to
pause the video here and try to figure
out what furiosa had in mind in this
position while I'll give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on figuring out what
the OSHA had in mind and for those of
you who just want to enjoy so if you
found rook to e1 or ecaptions' and these
six congratulations and of course as
both of it works the point is if rook e1
pawn captures pawn is the next move and
if pawn cap respond a rook to e1 is the
next move
so here he captures on d6 was plate and
now you kind of have to capture the
night otherwise the knight can just go
back into the position d7 is also coming
so a lot of problems for black here so
you have to accept the piece sacrifice
we have rook captures NBA and now rook
to e1 the point is you want to go rook
to e7 followed by d7 and here came to a
fait with rook to e7 and now rook to d8
not allowing these seven but now the
other passed pawn starts marching
forward we have a six rook captures on
d6 and now a seven preparing a eight
queen and here rook to d8 for some
reason do both doesn't like rook to h6
putting his role behind the past Ponte
guard da H where he does it by playing
rook to d8 and here we have Luke the b7
now the threat is rook to b8 just
blocking the a8 square and then you
wanna Queen this pawn which you could
prevent by playing rook to e8 it's a
very nice move because you will never be
able to play rook to b8 otherwise
a-rockin just captures on a 7 however do
both tried Bishop the c6 here and okay
da 8 square is covered twice now Rock
the c7 attacking the bishop and the pawn
of course if the bishop moves Bishop
back to a 8 and now not going after the
pond right away that can always be
captured King to have to now viraja
wants to get his King as well as deep
into the position as possible to help
out with the attack get rid of this pawn
and then start pushing these two
connected pass pawns
so with g5 by black King to e3 we have
h6 and now g3 and here again what do you
play here Bishop to g6 was play the
point
is if you play a rook to e8 it's not
gonna not gonna do you much good a year
you're just giving white moves you're
just allowing whites to get as deep as
white ones into the position
so here dubov tried a different idea he
tried an active Flint Bishop to g6 just
going after the d3 pawn but it doesn't
work so feel free to pause the video
once again and try to find the winning
idea for firoozeh in this position again
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations truly a remarkable
endgame player and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
rook to b7 the threat is not rook to b8
and the point is that black no longer
has a rook to e8 if you block with rook
to e8 now rook to b8 comes with check so
there's no bishop on eh the block check
now you just have to trade and the white
gets a queen into the game so here Du
Bois played rook captures on d3 with
check King to f2 and now brought his
rook behind the passed pawn but still
rook to b8 comes with the check so Ruby
a check King to g7 and now a a queen
black of course has the trade rook
captures rook captures and now Bishop to
d3 going after the pawn but phir aaja
just prevents it and now it's rook and
three points against the bishop and
three pawns extremely difficult to hold
to a draw but of course do both will try
King to f6 weave king to e3 and now
Bishop the f1 going after the h3 pawn
with h4 captures captures and now came
to e5 preventing the White King from
entering deeper into the position but
now look the a6 now you want to trade
the c4 pawn for the h6 pawn as there's
nothing you can really do to prevent
this Bishop captures on c4 with rook
captures on h6 and now Mercia back the
e6 we have ripped the g6 making no room
for the past H bond and Bishop sorry
that's a king Bishop to f5 we have
ripped the g1 not allowing anything to
cross the G file and into f6 with h5 by
future and now Bishop to h7 blocking the
pass pawn and now h6
with Bush up to g6 now again blocking
the rook and the pond but the problem is
the king can never go after the point
you can't go this way and well you can
never touch the g7 square if you go for
example to g8 then the route will just
capture the bishop so the black king is
pretty much hopeless here so King to d2
with King to f7 white black just has to
repeat moves King c3 with King f6 King C
for Bishop to f7 check King captures on
c5 you've eliminated the pawn Russia
back to g6 and now King to d6 with King
to f7 and now King 35 a crucial move to
win the same game as now the king can no
longer make a move as there are no
squares left that you can go to to
defend your Bishop here so you have to
play with the Bishop Bishop to d3 and
now finally rip the g7 check you are
winning the h7 Square King f8 and it was
in this position as Du Bois played King
to a fate that also he resigned the game
he resigned as there is nothing more to
do here
King f6 would be played after black
makes any move you're just gonna go h7
and here you have to give up your Bishop
and now it's just a very quick mating
sequence to follow
so after King to a fate dual resigned
and a brilliant and a very important win
for all areas of Eurasia taking down the
nil double-crossin second not an easy
task and it was good that he could do it
before taking the game into the rapid
section as Lubo is just a beast in in
rapid chess I sure do Bob is out of the
competition and I don't know who I
haven't checked who fear Allah is facing
in round 3 but it is gonna be be very
exciting as he gets one step closer to
that candidates tournament as if you've
missed it for some reason the two the
players who two players who do best in
the video World Cup get get a seat in
the feeder candidates tournament the the
determine the Challenger of Magnus
Carlsen so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Kenny
Archibald christian pope quarantine
salir margins mark Jensen and twitch
streamer for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
usually you can check two of my previous
videos here thank y'all for watching and
I will see you soon a continuing the
coverage of the World Cup checking up on
your wonderful suggestion such as this
one and and well doing what we usually
do so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
Sunday